und damit J Leute was geht herzlich
Willkommen zu ein neuen Video ich bin
hier gerade in Hannover am Hauptbahnhof
und hier fährt heute der nightjet
491 nach Wien Hauptbahnhof bzw innsbruru
Hauptbahnhof wir Pimmeln hier jetzt
mittlerweile schon seit fast zwei
Stunden rum weil das Ding hat einfach
eben war es 90 Minuten jetzt sind es nur
noch 70 Minuten Verspätung kurzes
Storytelling ich wollte mit meinem
Kollegen zusammen noch in Skiurlaub
fahren zi D Tage einfach vor Weihnachten
das Ding war Flüge waren richtig teuer
wir wollten auch nicht mit dem Auto
fahren weil einfach zu anstrengend und
dann bin ich auf die Idee gekommen wegen
vielen von euch ihr schreibt mal Alex es
gibt da so einen neuen nightet da gibt
es so mini cabins und noch ganz viel
neuen Quatsch und ich dachte mir komm
ich schaue einfach mal nach habe
tatsächlich noch einen freien Platz
gefunden und diesen Zug für uns beide
gebucht wir starten jetzt in Hannover
und sind dann morgen früh um 9 Uhr
Innsbruck wenn es halt gut läuft ich bin
mal gespannt ich nehme euch natürlich
wieder best möglich mit auf ein geilen
Skiurlaub ich werde euch auch noch
einiges von Vorort zeigen und jetzt
warten wir erstmal auf den Zug der
müsste gleich
kommen wie ist die Lage 6 Minuten noch
ich muss sagen wenn man hier mal so
rumfilmt hier ist einfach gar nichts los
also wir sind eigentlich fast die
einzigen die da einsteigen hier am
ganzen gleich sind vielleicht noch 15
andere Personen aber ist ja eigentlich
ganz gut dann wird schön leer sein und
ich kann das gut inspizieren alles ich
dachte der ist wenigstens pünktlich weil
der hat ja glaube ich nichts mit der
deutschen warn zu tun aber
[Musik]
Fehlanzeige jetzt erstmal noch K laufen
ach so klar man kann auch sitzen h ich
dachte eigentlich das ist ein reiner
schlafzug also mit so Sachen geh mal
rein weil nachher der wartet ja
nicht kann mein Koffer ruhig nehmen oder
ne Rig geht das also sieht auf jeden
Fall echt alles ziemlich neu aus hier
wie wenn man sein neues Auto abholt dann
mal ab zu den Mini cabins ich glaube wir
haben ultra wenig Platz ah ja das sind
die schon
aber wir können wenigstens nebeninander
schlafen und da kann man auch so eine
Trennwand wegmachen ist doch romantisch
so angekommen 403 Hannover Götting
Würzburg Nürnberg Augsburg München
Rosenheim Innsbruck ach so
ist natürlich die Frage wie wir hier
reinkommen so also ich könn jetzt
theoretisch schon rein alle anderen
müssen noch warten und wie ist dein
erster Eindruck ich bin positiv
überrascht fin eigentlich auch ganz gut
wir haben sogar ein Fenster steigt
schaut gemütlich aus fahren Sie öfter
Nachtzug schon ja aber jetzt noch nicht
mit dem wir auch oder ich auch nicht
wirkt eigentlich ganz gut ne ja der ist
recht neu das stimmt ja ich geh mal
klettern kann man die von innen
aufmachen warte okay hier ist mein
Fenster ah die kann ich
aufmachen und das ist die von Julian du
bin drin kannst du hier auch aufmachen
ich guck
mal
[Gelächter]
diese beiden
hier was nein noch nicht
dankeal wie kann man das hier aufmachen
mit Karte einfach alles klar danke muss
sagen du gutes Konzept also echt das
auch wirklich bequem man hat halt hier
nur so eine Decke aber kann man nicht
meckern willst du hier oder dain so
jetzt schutuch hier mal die Technik an
zack dann geht das hier automatisch auf
ich habe bisschen Probleme mit dem Film
weil zu eng ist aber hier kann man jetzt
dann die Sachen rein
verstauen geil ja ich habe extra oben
genommen sind unter uns welche ist
keiner aber das sind noch Kabinen ach ja
krass stimmt ja ja okay ich habe extra
oben gewählt hier ist sogar noch ein
Haken für die Jacke nehmen wir mal das
Kissen mit also für die die mal fragen
ich bin so knapp 180 und ich kann hier
so gerade liegen also wenn man jetzt 2 m
groß ist wird das wird das
schwierig verkehrt ist gar nicht
schlecht ne also die haben sich auf
jeden Fall was dabei gedacht wir haben
halt nur 150 € bezahlt pro Person so
ungefähr also ich finde das okay also
okay ist auch schon recht teuer ne wenn
du ein Flug frühzeitig buchst kommst du
günstiger weg aber so ist das natürlich
klimafreundlicher und liegt da mein
Rucksack unten noch beide noch Z zu ne
aber zu ne muss muss mir Fragen dass uns
aufchließen ja also erster Eindruck ist
wirklich geil das einzige Problem was
hier alle haben alle Passagiere diese
Bettlaken hier unten die ja da drunter
kommen also das stinkt hier alles so
noch Fisch boah Alter das geht ja
wirklich gar nicht also ich übertreibe
jetzt auch nicht aber das ist ja ja lass
das also ich werde auf jeden Fall nur
diese Decke hier verwenden es sieht ja
auch eigentlich recht hygienisch aus wir
schauen uns jetzt noch einmal grob den
Zug an bevor wir dann gleich schlafen
gehen hier haben wir dann auf jeden Fall
die richtigen Schlafkabinen also das
sind richtige Zimmer eigentlich sieht
auch echt gut aus muss ich sagen also
top modern alles und wir schauen mal ob
es auch ein Essensangebot jetzt noch
gibt bzw ob es überhaupt so ein
Restaurantwagen gibt das Gefühl ist ist
alles leer äh ja die schlafen alle schon
das war's hier das war oh stop kommt da
nichts
mehr kann man da rausgucken ja Alter wir
sind ganz hinten Leute so schauen wir
uns mal kurz die Herrentoilette an also
eine Dusche gibt's hier jetzt zumindest
nicht es kann sein dass es in den
schlafwegen eine eigene Dusche gibt aber
ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher ja aber
echt viel Platz muss man sagen es ist
eine echt große Zugtoilette wir machen
uns weiter auf Tour so und hier sind wir
auch schon am anderen Ende des Zuges
also es gibt halt anscheinend wirklich
nicht viel hier also kein b b also das
zugp macht hier anscheinend das
Frühstück selber in dieser kleinen
Miniküche aber ist ja cool wir sind auf
jeden Fall jetzt auch schon in Göttingen
so schöne putchen hier gibt's noch so
ein extra waschbeckenbereich und dann
geht's ab in der haer Morgen fit sein
für Skifahren endlich in der Kabine und
soweit Bett fertig bevor ich euch jetzt
noch einmal ganz kurz hier die Kabine
erkläre weil hier gibt's echt einige
coole neue Features ich bin mir auch
sicher die gibt's in den alten
Nachtzügen von ÖBB nicht wollte ich euch
ganz kurz einmal auf den echt coolen
Sponser des heutigen Videos aufmerksam
machen und zwar aus folgenden Gründen
ich habe mir noch ein neues Content
Handy geholt das ist ein iPhone 15 pro
das werde ich einfach nur für meine
Reisen benutzen wenn ich irgendwo ja
gibt halt viele Situationen wo es halt
sinnvoll ist mit Handy zu filmen und die
haben mir das Ganze handyzbehör dafür
gesponsort wie z.B hier diese Kickstand
wireless Powerbank echt super man hat
immer Akku und noch ganz viel mehr das
stelle ich euch aber alles im
Hotelzimmer vor weil da habe ich mehr
Zeit und auch mehr Platz okay wir sind
mittlerweile auf dem Berg und ich dachte
mir eigentlich ist es ja viel cooler
weil ich habe das Handy eh dabei euch
die Produkte unterwegs hier vorzustellen
anstatt im Hotel das hier ist mein neues
iPhone 15 pro mein Content Handy das
Case hier ist auch schon von ESR aber
jetzt passt mal auf ich habe mich nicht
len lassen und extra ein Produkt mit auf
dem Berg zu nehmen hier haben wir die
ESR Halo Loock Wallet stand ihr könnt
schon erkennen quasi in portme wir haben
hier einen 20% stärkeren Magnet als
marktüblich integriert und so könnt ihr
euch ganz praktisch euer portmone sparen
hier eure Karten reinstecken und es rein
theoretisch auch so hinstellen wobei das
würde ich jetzt hier ungern machen sonst
habe ich gleich mein Handy verloren
weiter geht's mit diesem Softcase das
habe ich auch die ganze Zeit schon um
mein iPhone 15 pro rum das Gute ist
hierbei es sieht schön aus und man hat
einmal ein kameragard das heißt die
Kamera ist gut geschützt und ihr könnt
das Ding aber auch aufklappen um es dann
entspannt hinzustellen also wirklich
eine praktische Hülle wireless charging
natürlich möglich noch mal als kleine
Demonstration zack dranpappen lät zu
guter Letzt das habe ich auch noch
mitgenommen wir haben noch ein
durchsichtiges handycase mir gefällt die
titanfarbe beim neuen iPhone super gut
deswegen vielleicht sogar das Richtige
für mich machen wir die mal drum sieht
auch nice aus leute es wird wieder
windig vielen Dank an ESR fürs sponsorn
dieses Videos checkt die Links in der
Videobeschreibung ab falls ihr euch für
die Produkte interessiert und wir testen
jetzt weiter den nightjet jetzt erkläre
ich euch noch einmal die Kabine hier
Steckdose zack selbst USB-Anschluss hier
noch eine Leselampe bis jetzt nichts
Besonderes das interessante kommt jetzt
eigentlich erst wir haben hier eine
Anzeige hier kann man einmal sehen wenn
die Toilette benutzt ist oder sogar das
Zimmer zum Hände waschen hier kann man
denke ich sein Kaffee morgen früh ordern
wenn man wach ist jetzt brauche ich den
noch nicht Licht aus aha RGB Funktion
wie geht das an hier wahrscheinlich ja
Alter und wie kann man die Farbe
wechseln jetzt ist es einfach so blau ah
ja du musst einfach aufs Plus und Minus
drücken dann wechselt er die Farbe jetzt
haben wir hier red light das Bettlagen
habe ich jetzt weggelassen das hat mir
zu sehr nach Fisch gestunken so ein
kleines Kissen ist auch dabei also wenn
man jetzt wirklich 190 groß ist oder
über 190 hat man ein Problem weil ich
merke da hinten auch schon das Ende
sonst gibt's eigentlich nichts mehr groß
zu melden wenn man zu zweit fährt kriegt
man halt Kabinen nebeneinander und kann
das hier auf und zu machen wenn man
keinen Bock auf die andere Person hat
aber eigentlich können wir das auflassen
ich habe da nichts gegen was das Ding
größer dadurch ja das stimmt das wirkt
größer und hier ist halt auch direkt ein
Fenster das ist auch ganz geil weißt du
ob in Innsbruck Schnee liegt schon weil
das wäre ja geil wenn wir wieder im
Schnee ankommen so wie bei dem letzten
Nachtzug dem Polar Express nach rovanemi
na ja gute Nacht ich glaube viel kann
ich jetzt nicht mehr mitfilmen es gibt
auch eigentlich nichts spannendes mehr
ich habe euch schon alles gezeigt fahzit
zum Zug machen wir dann noch mal wenn
wir in ach so ich habe noch gar nicht
gesagt wo wir hinfahren wir fahren zum
stuhbeayer Gletscher da soll man wohl
auch ziemlich gut Abriss Ski machen
genau das Richtige für uns und geiles
Skigebiet so sieht's draußen aus man
kann gerade ein bisschen was sehen
kleine Ergänzung noch man braucht keine
europack es ist super krass gedämmt das
muss ich sagen ich glaube noch besser
als in dem Zug in Finnland und der war
schon richtig gut aber hier merkt man
wirklich das ist deutsche ingenieursk ne
der kommt ja aus Österreich netim von
Siemens ja stimmt der ist von Siemens du
hast recht das ist deutsche
Ingenieurskunst super Zuch ich bin
begeistert es gibt hier keinen
Temperaturregler man kann aber hier das
Dingen aufklappen dann kommt hier so ein
kleines Lüftchen raus ja schon relativ
frisch ich mache das glaube ich zu weil
es ist auf jeden Fall schon recht
angenehm also nicht zu warm nicht zu
kalt was ist das denn hier für ein Bums
ist unser Zug kaputt oder was Tür kaputt
fand du es auch kalt
zieht hier so ja
übel sehr geehrte Fahrgäste aufgrund
einer technischen Störung wird dieser
Zug voraussichtlich nicht weiterfahren
immer das gleiche hier in
deutschlandlich ich will doch nur
Skifahren man wo ist mein
Frühstück so wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich in Augsburg raus ich habe so
semi gut geschlafen eigentlich ist es
recht bequem nur es ist so kalt gewesen
ich hoffe ich habe mich nicht erkältet
ich glaube alle sind mittlerweile schon
ausgestiegen außer wir also mit Schnee
aus dem Fenster Aufwachen ist ist nicht
oh das sieht ja klasse aus am mäßig
danke ist das Kaffee ja da kann man
natürlich jetzt nicht meckern Brötchen
Marmelade und Kaffee und Besteck ist
deine Butter auch eingefroren das wä
jetzt noch der Höhepunkt wenn mein
Holzmesser durchbricht weil die Butter
weil die Butter eingefroren ist ja geil
aber man muss ja fairerweise auch sagen
ist ja auch ein Nachtzug und wir haben
wir jetzt schon Tag kan man sogar hier
nach hinten schieben wenn der jetzt
pünktig gewesen wäre und hier diese
Kältekammer nicht entstanden wäre wäre
ich echt top zufrieden gewesen
tschüss da war alles raus
ne ja das war ja nichts ne jetzt stehen
wir hier in Augsburg und der Zug ist
kaputt hier sind übrigens noch die
liegewegen mit diesem vieran zu viert
kann man hier halt rein ne ist das der
Schlafwagen oh ja ja doch das ist das
und ich weiß nicht ob da eine Dusche
drin ist habe ich immer noch nicht
ermitteln können aber kann sein das
sieht schon echt ganz geil aus da gibt's
ja auch sogar Matratzen ne aber die
Leute die das gebucht haben sind jetzt
auch noch nicht am Ziel oh man also ich
muss sagen der Zug ist eigentlich echt
gut auch das Konzept der Mini Camin
gefällt mir also wenn man mal mit Zug
fahren will oder Nachtzug so einfach mal
was anderes ausprobieren möchte kann ich
das auf jeden Fall empfehlen gerade zu
zweit war halt wie gesagt sag ein
bisschen kalt und dass der Zug jetzt
irgendein Defekt hat ich meine das Ding
fährt seit di Wochen das regt mich schon
wieder so auf ne wir sind hier in
Deutschland und die Züge kannst du
komplett knicken ich weiß es ist in
österreichischer Zug aber es ist einfach
Katastrophe wirklich nicht mal in
Rumänien bleibt der Nachtzug irgendwo
steht das muss man sich mal vorstellen
also jetzt nichts gegen Rumänien aber da
sah es teilweise aus als wären die Züge
von
1922 muss ich mir mal kurz über aufregen
weil wir wollen natürlich Skifahren
ne
so auch mal da zweinhalb Stunden zu spät
wir werden schon längst auf Piste
so was wir haben gerade auf jeden Fall
eingecheckt jetzt schnell hier in Skibus
und ab auf dem Berg aber sieht geil aus
[Musik]
oder so wir sind jetzt hier ganz oben
beim stuher Gletscher auf 3100 m also es
ist echt hoch ich habe meine eigenen Ski
zu Hause gelassen und hier jetzt le die
sind 10 cm länger als meine also 177
habe mich gerade schon zweimal aufs Maul
gelegt weil ich bisschen die Kontrolle
verloren habe aber so langsam geht's
[Musik]
jetzt
UPS an dieser Stelle noch ein kleines
Fazit zum Nachtzug also ich muss sagen
an sich wirklich topmoderner Zug und man
kann da gut drin pennen also ist war
eine gute Alternative und ich würde
jedem empfehlen das mal zu testen Ken
ich bis jetzt nur die Mini cabins ich
glaube die richtigen schlafabteile sind
auch ganz geil da haben wir einmal kurz
reingefilmt das einzige was ich sagen
muss und wozu ich kein Vergleichswert
hab ist wie oft dieser Zug denn wirklich
pünktlich kommt oder kaputt geht weil es
kann ja wirklich nicht sein dass er bei
uns 90 Minuten Verspätung hatte und dann
auch noch in Augsburg kaputt geht wegen
einer defekten Tür wenn sowas öfter
passiert da hat man ja keinen Bock drauf
so will ich nicht in Urlaub fahren und
ja ist ja auch Quatsch sonst war cool
hast du noch irgendwas zu ergänzen oder
fandst du es gut ja also mein erster
Eindruck war hervor fragend ich dachte
auch da könnte ich schlafen wie ein Baby
aber
Pustekuchen ja du hast nicht so gut
geschlafen ne ich muss sagen weil ich
jetzt öfter schon in Nachtzügen
genechtig habe dass es eigentlich
mittlerweile klar geht vor allem der war
echt gut isoliert also die haben sich
dabei schon was gedacht danke fürs
zuschauen Leute abonniert den Kanal für
weitere coole Reisevideos im Januar
geht's für mich wieder ganz weit weg und
ich glaube bis dahin sehen wir uns
leider hier nicht mehr wieder aber wir
schauen mal vielleicht doch haut rein
frohe Weihnachten und
guten Rutsch keine Ahnung wann das Video
kommt aber ja danke für den Support dies
J und wir sehen uns dann nächstes Jahr
wieder Ciao da soll man wohl auch
ziemlich gut abrissi machen genau das
Richtige für
[Musik]
uns